bonsoir merci de nous rejoindre pour le
7 8 lecture le journal de la rédaction
sur TVfil le 78 il est 18h si vous nous
suivez en direct et comme chaque soir
nous commençons par les principaux
titres qui seront développés au cours de
la prochaine demi-heure les avocats du
Barreau de Versailles et dans la rue
aujourd'hui devant le palais de justice
pour montrer au gouvernement leur
mécontentement et leurs inquiétudes
concernant le budget alloué par l'État
l'aide juridictionnelle dans un instant
c'est le bâtonnier de Versailles qui
nous en dira plus sur ce plateau Renault
Mégane Peugeot 208 elles sont en
apparence banale mais elle dissimule des
radars de dernière génération capable de
flasher les dépassements par la gauche
et les excès de vitesse dans les deux
sens ces véhicules sillonnent depuis peu
de département 164 arbres symbolisant
les 164 personnes accompagnées par le
cabinet de recrutement ABC fort value
planté aujourd'hui dans les jardins et
parcs du château de Thoiry opération
symbolique et qui permettent à
l'établissement de conforter son imagé
correspondable nous en parlerons aussi
auto aura de cette table avec les
principaux protagonistes
l'image du jour la société Cocktail
Games qui vient d'être pris mais en
Allemagne la PME versaillesse
spécialisée dans les jeux de société a
reçu le titre de jeu de l'année pour
anabi qui se base sur la mémoire et au
cours duquel les participants doivent
par participer à la réalisation d'un des
plus beaux feux d'artifice vous voyez
les images de ce jeu Cocktail Games
s'est fait connaître en 2003 avec un jeu
politique casse-toi pauvre con 250 000
exemplaires vendus pour ce clin d'oeil
assumé à une déclaration de l'ancien
président Sarkozy les avocats du Barreau
de Versailles se sont réunis au palais
de justice de la ville pour protester
contre la réforme du financement de
l'aide juridictionnelle il dénonce une
diminution du budget et réclame un
dialogue avec la ministre Christianne
topira les explications d'Olivier
Maniscalco et d'Élodie moine
les avocats du Barreau de Versailles en
colère ce mardi il se réunissait
symboliquement au palais de justice pour
protester contre le désengagement de
l'État dans le financement de l'aide
juridictionnelle cette aide permet à
tous d'accéder à la justice et d'être
défendu par un avocat financé par l'État
avec 30 millions d'euros à louer en
moins dès 2015 pour cette aide les
avocats ne s'y retrouveraient plus
financièrement il redoute également que
sans financement les dossiers
bénéficiants de cette aide de
juridictionnelle soit traitée sans
considération et confié à des avocats
sans expérience la balance de la justice
serait donc menacée le problème de la
juridictionnelle c'est que ça fait 10
ans que les questions sont posées et
qu'il n'y a aucune solution qui n'a été
raté par l'État alors que la profession
a fait des propositions excessivement
sérieuses la seule réforme qui avait été
envisagée était de faire une taxe sur le
chiffre d'affaires des avocats c'est
accepter aux avocats de financer sur
leur activité l'accès aux droits ce qui
est totalement invraisemblable c'était
comme si on demandait au médecin de
payer sur leurs honoraires les soins
qu'ils allaient prodiguer à leur patient
les avocats lament aujourd'hui une
concertation avec la ministre de la
Justice Christiane Taubira concernant le
financement de cette juridictionnelle de
leur côté ils proposent d'instaurer une
taxe sur les actes juridiques pour
assurer leur rémunération
et je reçois donc Olivier fontibus
bonsoir bâtonnier des avocats à
Versailles merci d'avoir répondu à notre
invitation on va commencer par clarifier
un petit peu votre combat cette aide
juridictionnelle dont il était question
qu'il a sollicite en général ça
s'adresse à qui et dans quel cas très
précis alors au plus démunis puisque
l'aide juridictionnelle permet aux
personnes qui ont une rémunération un
revenu extrêmement bas moins de 600 700
euros de bénéficier de l'assistant d'un
avocat on parle de 30 millions d'euros
en moins accordés par l'État quelles
conséquences effectivement le budget de
l'aide de juridictionnelle est au niveau
national d'environ 235 millions le
gouvernement avait décidé il y a de cela
un mois de baisser ce budget de près de
30 millions à l'époque nous avions bougé
nous aussi on mobilisés nous avions
interpellé le garde des sceaux et le 4
octobre dernier madame Taubira nous a
annoncé qu'elle revenait sur sa réforme
et qu'elle annulait effectivement cette
diminution de la juridictionnelle de 30
millions et finalement et finalement
l'autre pendant de s'engagement c'était
effectivement d'ouvrir des discussions
cela fait près de 20 ans que nous
discutons sur une augmentation de la
juridictionnelle aujourd'hui ce budget
n'a pas augmenté depuis 2007 et les
avocats travaillent à perte depuis des
années parce que cet argent pour être
très clair il est versé à qui aux
avocats qui défendent justement les
citoyens qui n'ont pas les moyens des
dossiers qui acceptent
l'état indemnise l'avocat je parle pas
de rémunération mais d'une indemnisation
qui est en dessous du seuil de
rentabilité des cabinets selon quels
critères comment se fait l'indépendance
d'un système de duvet d'unité de valeur
chaque dossier vaut en duvet par exemple
un divorce ça vaut 30 UV et l'UV est à
23 euros ce qui fait à peu près 600
euros pour un divorce alors que que le
prix d'un divorce du Racl classique peut
évoluer entre 2000 et 3000 euros ce sont
des affaires des dossiers en tant
qu'avocat vous êtes obligé d'assumer
alors il y a pas d'obligation les
avocats sont volontaires pour assurer
ses missions la juridictionnelle civile
ou pénal sur Versailles par exemple
exemple c'est un volontaire là pas un
bon notariat pur absolument et ça
fonctionne bien mais ça vous casses sont
volontaires si aucun avocat n'est
volontaire comment ça peut être les
avocats volontaires il y a plus sur 750
confrères à Versailles près de 300
assume ses missions de la
juridictionnelle à plus ou moins grand
échelle quelques dossiers beaucoup de
dossiers c'est une liberté absolue mais
ces missions nous les assumons
totalement et pleinement vous disiez
tout à l'heure un budget de 235 millions
à l'échelle de l'Hexagone il est de 2
milliards en Grande-Bretagne ce sont les
chiffres que vous avancez lorsque vous
comparez un petit peu les choses comme
on peut expliquer ce gouffre ce grand
écart entre les deux pays moi je pense
que la justice en France ajoute toujours
été le parent pauvre le budget de la
justice en France et et minable nous
sommes je crois le 43e pays en Europe
après des pays comme l'Azerbaïdjan donc
pourtant ce média augmente globalement
il augmente toujours un petit peu mais
dans le budget de la justice qui
augmente surtout c'est la part pour le
pénitentiaire c'est-à-dire pour
construire des prisons ça on en a de
très gros financements mais la justice
elle-même il y a de moins en et
s'agissant de l'aide juridictionnelle ce
qui permet l'accès aux droits on parle
de l'accès aux droits de permettre à
plus en plus de gens d'avoir accès aux
droits accès au juge c'est une belle
chose mais l'accès au droit signifie
l'accès à l'avocat et l'accès à l'avocat
c'est la juridictionnelle ça veut dire
que les choix en France des différents
gouvernements par uniquement de celui-ci
mais des précédents également ce ne sont
pas des bons choix en termes de justice
ce ne sont pas des bons choix puisqu'ils
ont demandé à une profession libérale
d'assumer seul la solidarité nationale
permettre à toute individu en France
quel que soit son revenu d'avoir accès à
la justice c'est une question de
solidarité nationale de budget national
or c'est la profession d'avocat qui
assume en gros ce poids de charge vous
parlez d'un budget globalement par en
pauvre pour la pour la justice pour
autant il y a des économies à faire et
ça touche tous les secteurs quelles
solutions vous pouvez proposer sans une
fois de plus creuser le déficit de
l'État tout à fait l'avocats sont
conscients des limites du budget de
l'État c'est la raison pour laquelle le
doublement ou le triplement de ce budget
passe par des financement extérieur à
celui de l'État bien que ce soit une
question de solidarité nationale nous
avons fait des propositions le Conseil
national des barreaux qui est notre
institution représentative au niveau
national a depuis des années
proposer des solutions vous l'avez
indiqué dans votre reportage il s'agit
notamment de la taxation de tous les
actes juridiques en France qui
permettraient de doubler à tout le moins
ce budget ça te permettrait aussi
effectivement d'avoir à intégrer la
protection juridique les assureurs
gagnent beaucoup d'argent sur la
protection juridique on pourrait là
aussi les solliciter ça peut se
retourner sur les assurés les contrats
d'assurance plus élevés il faudra
forcément quelqu'un qui paye de taxes
les taxes aujourd'hui c'est pas
forcément très à la mode non ce n'est
pas à la mode c'est une évidence mais il
faut trouver des moyens pour alimenter
ce budget qui correspond à un élément de
la solidarité nationale et ce n'est pas
aux avocats de l'assumer seul
mobilisation aujourd'hui pas uniquement
d'ailleurs à Versailles sur l'ensemble
de la France on imagine vous ferez
bientôt un bilan voir si cette opération
bien fonctionné auprès des différents
avocats mais est-ce qu'il est d'ores et
déjà prévu d'autres actions alors tout
dépendra effectivement de la façon dont
la Chancellerie va n'était pas une grève
aujourd'hui de mobilisation pour faire
comprendre la chance elle rit qui a
ouvert des discussions que ces
discussions doivent continuer
aujourd'hui ce qu'on nous propose dans
le projet de réforme de la loi de
finances 2014 c'est de faire avec de
faire mieux avec moins nous disons que
nous ne pouvons pas gérer la pénurie ou
de sollicitons de la Chancellerie
d'ouverture de vrais négociations pour
discuter de ses propositions qui
permettraient effectivement un jour
d'arriver à une vraie rémunération mais
plus à une indemnisation indigne pour un
pays comme la France vous parlez d'un
Grenelle de la juridictionnelle parce
que ça signifie bien ce que ça veut dire
c'est à dire d'ouvrir un dossier de
mettre les partenaires autour d'une
table et de discuter voilà amenons
autour de la table les compagnies
d'assurance toutes les professions
voisines de celle de la désavocats la
Chancellerie la poissonnerie discutons
de l'accès aux droits puisque c'est
effectivement le bon ordre est-ce pour
l'instant les discussions semblent en
bonne voie est-ce que ça pourrait être
envisagé envisageable est-ce que la
Garde des Sceaux a répondu à cette
mobilisation aujourd'hui par exemple la
connaissance elle n'a pas répondu elle
avait répondu le 4 octobre façon
effectivement satisfaisante puisque le
projet dont vous parlez tout à l'heure
avait été abandonné d'autres projets qui
étaient aussi néfastes pour la
profession avait été abandonnée nous
espérions l'ouverture des négociations
fructueuse or nous nous apercevons un
mois plus tard que nous allons dans une
voie qui n'est pas la bonne une grève
est possible une grève peut-être pas
mais des mouvements d'humeur du barreau
le bâtonnier par exemple le procès de
désignation des avocats à la
juridictionnelle que ce soit au pédalo
civil il se pourrait effectivement que
nous faisions là aussi une suspension de
ces désignations ça pourrait intervenir
rapidement ah ça peut aller ça peut
intervenir demain si nous n'avons pas
cette extaction évidemment merci Olivier
fontibus d'être venu sur ce plateau
bâtonnier des avocats de Versailles
mobilisé donc aujourd'hui avec vos
différents confrères l'autre actualité
de ce 5 novembre c'est la présence sur
les routes du département
de nouveaux radars ils sont capables de
flasher les véhicules qui circulent dans
les deux sens de circulation les
nouveaux radars embarqués sont en
service et il fonctionne comme on peut
le constater en tenir et chez Patrick
Jacques de Dixmude
vous l'avez peut-être croisé sans vous
en rendre compte le radar nouvelle
génération roule dans les Yvelines
installé dans un véhicule banalisé en
mouvement le système peut contrôler des
véhicules dans les deux sens de
circulation et jusqu'à 4 voies parallèle
sauf en cas de terre plein centrale il
est indétectable par les avertisseurs de
radar mais surtout par les automobiles
l'idée la philosophie se dispositif
c'est de créer au point des objets de la
route un sentiment d'insécurité non pas
négatif mais qu'il y avait plutôt
destiné à les rendre vigilants sur leur
propre conduite leur propre comportement
sur leur environnement de manière bien
sûr essayer toujours et encore de faire
diminuer le nombre de tués sur les
routes mais qui dit nouvelle génération
dit budgets ce nouveau système coûte 70
000 euros et un seul véhicule sera
équipé dans le département autre aspect
la marge de tolérance est augmentée de 5
km/h pour les radars classiques cela
passe à 10 km/h jusqu'à 100 km/h et 10%
de la ainsi les petits excès de vitesse
ne sont pas prises en compte là comme
vous pouvez le voir le radar
a flashé un véhicule qui venait en sens
inverse de nous il roulait à 106 km/h
pour une vitesse de 90 donc
cette personne va recevoir l'avis de
contravention chez elle
à savoir donc une amende à 45 euros et
un retrait de 1 point et pour être
flashé il doit y avoir un écart de
vitesse de 20 km/h entre les deux
véhicules lors de notre essai d'une
vingtaine de minutes le radar à
contrôler 83 automobilistes pour 4
infractions répertoriées depuis le début
de l'année 46 personnes ont trouvé la
mort sur les routes linoises dont les
deux tiers à cause d'excès de vitesse
et que pensez-vous de ces nouveaux
radars vous le savez chaque soir vous
réagissez aux différents sujets
d'actualité sur notre antenne voici le
micro-trottoir de ce mardi mon avis
personnel ça va me donner des chances de
prendre des points en moins après sur le
fond si statistiquement démontre que ça
fait baisser le nombre de morts sur la
route c'est forcément bon quoi c'est pas
juste parce qu'on est toujours là pour
être contrôlé c'est pénible tout à fait
pour que ce soit c'est leur métier
d'abord de nous indiquer que il y a des
lois il y a des il y a des règles à
respecter il y a le code de la route qui
est valable pour tout le monde estime
qu'on paye déjà assez on fait attention
sur les routes il y a des limitations
moi je les respecte en général si en
plus parce que je dépasse de 10 km à
l'heure je vais me faire avoir un une
amende bah non je suis contre voilà
ce n'est pas en tout cas un nouveau
véhicule qui aidera la police à résoudre
ce mystère du côté du Technocentre à
Guyancourt vient d'apprendre que le 30
octobre un adolescent de 17 ans a été
retrouvé inconscient sur ce site
appartenant à Renault la police
judiciaire de Versailles cherche
toujours à expliquer les causes de ce
qui semble une agression plongée dans le
coma Carson pronostic vital était engagé
à la victime c'est réveillé hier mais
n'a pas encore été interrogé les caméras
à de surveillance n'ont rien filmer
originaire de Bretagne le jeune homme
n'a jamais travaillé pour la
marcolosange il était venu rendre visite
à un ami dans le département
l'avenir du bureau à Yvelines
informations jeunesse à Versailles
toujours un certain nous en avons déjà
parlé sur ce plateau l'association qui
intervient auprès des jeunes pour les
questions d'emploi de logement de
formation n'a plus de directeur depuis
le 1er novembre elle les employait aux
manifesté fin octobre le conseil général
qui gère une partie de la structure
propose une réunion d'ici le milieu du
mois on écoute Laurence cousin adjoint à
la direction et d'Yvelines informations
jeunesse c'est au micro d'Olivier
Maniscalco
le fait de pas avoir d'interlocuteur
c'était vraiment pour nous vraiment très
angoissant sur le futur de la structure
maintenant il faut que ce soit suivi
d'acte donc on espère vraiment que il y
aura très prochainement un président
c'est la première urgence présidente
trésorier et puis après un directeur ou
une directrice tant que c'est pas
installé mis en place
on reste vigilant effectivement donc il
y a toujours la pétition en ligne on
atteint les 200 signatures mais la
maintient pour l'instant effectivement
un arbre pour un emploi un boulot pour
un boulot plus précisément c'est le nom
d'une opération menée aujourd'hui à
Thoiry par le cabinet ABC forvial value
164 arbres plantés une opération qui
permet de symboliser des emplois créés
elle les précisions avec Claire Cambier
et Jonathan villemann avant d'en parler
en plateau avec deux nouveaux invités
une opération de reboisement un peu
particulière s'est déroulée au parc de
Thoiry ce mardi à l'initiative du projet
un cabinet de recrutement le projet un
boulot pour un boulot a permis de
planter 164 arbres dont des bouleaux
symbolisant les 164 personnes
accompagnées par abaisser faux Valio ce
qui est important pour nous c'est que
notre entreprise participe à son échelle
à effectivement le développement durable
et donc planter des arbres énormément de
symboliques à la fois dans le domaine de
l'environnement puisqu'on plante un
arbre il va pousser va grandir mais
c'est également voilà quand on plante
quelqu'un dans une entreprise c'est pour
qui grandisse c'est pour qu'il apporte
de la valeur voilà donc la symbolique
pour nous est extrêmement liée cette
société en est à sa quatrième opération
de la sorte cette année elle a souhaité
agir en région parisienne
sur ses papiers le nom des personnes
placées par les 51 du groupe pour le
parc de Thoiry cette opération permet
d'enrichir son parc botanique décentrare
on a un vaste programme de reforestation
du domaine qui fait 155 hectares donc
chaque année on essaie de planter un
petit peu et donc là ce soutien nous a
vraiment aidé parce que ça nous a permis
de financer des essences très rares de
boulot mais aussi de pain qui viennent
de Chine pour découvrir les fruits de
cette initiative il ne vous reste que
quelques jours le parc ferme ses portes
dans une semaine
depuis cette année et je reçois donc ce
soir le compte Paul de la Panneuse
bonsoir sur ce plateau fondateur du parc
zoologique du château de Thoiry et
également Louis Gomer bonsoir à vous
vous êtes directeur associé du cabinet
ABC fort value on vient de voir le
déroulement de cette opération 164
arbres donc plantés ce sont 164
personnes que vous avez accompagnées
avec votre cabinet on peut peut-être
préciser ce qu'est justement ce cabinet
c'est quoi un cabinet d'acquisition et
de développement de talent alors ABC
fort adious c'est un cabinet qui existe
depuis 2003 était fondé à Nantes autour
des ressources humaines donc le point de
départ c'est effectivement l'entrée dans
l'entreprise c'est donc le recrutement
et au fil des années on a développé
effectivement notre propre approche dans
les ressources humaines dans les offres
que nous proposions au marché et en
l'occurrence on a monté des offres
doubles qui consiste à avoir une
prestation première comme leur coûtement
auquel on a créé un accompagnement
spécifique pendant la première année
d'intégration l'idée du coaching du
manage vous voyez si le salarié
s'intègre bien dans l'entreprise
exactement un peu comme on l'a vu à
l'image avec les arbres les arbres il
faut les planter mais il faut les
arroser nous on a pris effectivement ce
même principe cette même symbolique pour
l'appliquer à notre travail et c'est de
là qui est né l'acquisition et le
développement de talent
voilà vous êtes présent depuis 2003 donc
vous êtes installé depuis 2003 il y a
des cabinets sur Paris non traînent Lyon
également une quinzaine de
collaborateurs vos clients en PME c'est
plutôt effectivement des PME des PMI
également ce qui est important sont les
valeurs aussi donc il y a souvent des
entreprises à capital familial parce que
pour ces entreprises comme certains
groupes d'ailleurs la valeur humaine les
hommes qui composent les entreprises
c'est une valeur extrêmement forte et la
prestation les prestations qu'on propose
correspondent bien à leur valeur et
c'était aussi un peu le lien avec le
parc de Thoiry et c'est la raison d'être
aujourd'hui
ce partenariat vous les avez sollicités
l'opération existe depuis 2010 en chaque
automne en 2010 vous plantez ces
différents arbres exactement vous avez
déjà entendu entendu parler de cette
opération
par Louis grumet oui mais quand il a
choisi de venir sur Thouaré nous étions
tous extrêmement heureux parce que nous
sommes une famille qui accueille des
familles lui permet à un membre d'une
famille de s'enraciner dans une
entreprise et je trouve qu'elle
symbolique était nous avons un truc à
symbolique était très belle et
des boulots pour un boulot et nous
sommes très heureux d'accueillir ces 164
heures parce que il correspondent à une
histoire personnelle grâce à Louis
grumères et à son entreprise
c'est des c'est l'histoire de
60-64 familles qui sont racines dans
Thoiry pour toujours un souvenir qui va
agrandir qui va s'épanouir au soleil et
c'est quelque chose de pour nous de très
bien parce que c'est pas un arbre
anonyme qui est venu d'une pépinière si
rare soit-il c'est un arbre personnalisé
qui prend racine à toi et grâce à
louer
parce que c'est important pour
l'environnement l'écosystème de Thoiry
pour ces animaux qui sont présents aussi
vous avez veillé au boulot qui était
planté d'où viennent-ils
c'est parmi les arbres qui ont été
offerts par
l'entreprise Louis Robert et c'était les
arbres sont des arbres de qualité on ne
peut pas s'amuser de même que je pense
qu'il a choisi des gens de qualité pour
les entreprises où ils les mettaient
en tout cas les arbres sont vraiment
grande qualité il y a pas de on ne peut
pas s'amuser à mettre sur un arbre
contrairement à quelqu'un dans une
entreprise on peut passer d'une
entreprise à l'autre au cours d'une
carrière a priorité
enraciné un château monument historique
et un jardin où les arbres témoignent
d'une histoire familiale on parle
d'emploi aussi derrière ces arbres qui
sont plantés vous parlez de cette
symbolique aujourd'hui cette activité du
recrutement ça fonctionne bien malgré la
crise la difficulté le chômage les
mauvais chiffres écoutez
on passe une première période de l'année
où ça a été très compliqué on a dû faire
face effectivement un ralentissement
ralentissement avec parce qu'il y a eu
une forme de grippe de grippe
grippements entre
les entreprises qui ne recrutaient plus
et également les collaborateurs qui ne
souhaitaient plus bouger
à l'extérieur de l'entreprise là on sent
un peu plus de fluidité depuis quelques
semaines depuis la rentrée en définitive
quand vous montez une telle opération
c'est aussi pour vous faire connaître
c'est aussi une opération de
communication ça coûte cher une telle
opération ça coûte un budget de l'ordre
3 à 4000 euros environ tout compris
effectivement et vous le referez vous
savez déjà où vous allez planter les
prochains arbres ici j'imagine que vous
seriez content d'en accueillir de
nouveau encore l'année prochaine à
Thoiry ah oui mais j'ai le principe de
l'opération et d'aller dans différents
sites et nous avons été très heureux
d'avoir été choisis par ABC fort value
je dirais qu'aujourd'hui en tous les cas
entre Thoiry et nous c'est une histoire
j'allais dire d'amitié et de valeurs
c'est important et donc chaque année on
choisit effectivement des sites en
fonction de ces deux critères
ça peut être dans des communes
précédemment autour de Nantes ça a été
dans une autre famille d'entrepreneurs à
côté de Rennes il y a 4 maintenant
l'année prochaine on cherchera à tourner
effectivement géographiquement pour se
rapprocher de tous nos bureaux et que
chaque personne placée en France par
notre intermédiaire ou accompagner et
bien et son arbre proche de chez lui ces
opérations de développement durable on
va dire c'est pas une première pour toi
arrive au veillez justement
l'environnement construction écologique
et gestion des déchets réductions des
dépenses en énergie aussi c'est le
leitmotiv où vous imposez dans chacune
de vos décisions ce genre de choses ça
c'est ma fille et mes enfants maintenant
je suis très heureux de voir qu'ils font
évaluer le parc quand j'ai commencé il y
a
40 et quelques années j'étais comme un
fermier qui sud-africain qui a inventé
quelques trucs pour faire mettre tes
animaux ensemble sur des grands
territoires maintenant le niveau est
beaucoup plus haut parce que nous avons
deux vétérinaires et demi un ingénieur
environnemental 3 curateurs
un directeur de collection il y a un
niveau scientifique que l'on en est au
point de faire une ferme bio pour
pouvoir nourrir les insectes qui seront
mangés par les amphibiens avec des
fruits dont nous sommes sûrs qui n'ont
pas été traités aux pesticides alors
voilà l'opération de ABC fort value
rentre dans cette recherche de qualité
mais la qualité humaine est tout aussi
importante que la qualité sanitaire pour
les animaux et les arbres je ne toute
dernière question à vous poser de me
concerne pas cette opération mais on
avait évoqué sur cette antenne la hausse
de la TVA qui passerait à 10% en janvier
au lieu des 7% qui touchent votre part
vous souhaitiez un taux à 5,5% ce qui
marquerait aussi la différence avec les
parcs de loisirs qui sont taxés à mes
moteurs que vous 10% ou en est ce
dossier est-ce que vous avez
nous avons été très aimablement reçu par
Monsieur Benoît Hamon mon fils et moi
hier et il nous a dit qu'il essaierait
de faire son possible car effectivement
en plus il y a une terrible injustice
qui vient de ce que les cirques ont
récupéré le taux de 5 % et que nous ne
comprendriez pas que les parcs
zoologiques qui remplissent des missions
qui leur coûte très cher soit à 10 % de
TVA alors que les cirques ou c'est
l'espoir l'homme face à l'animal qui ne
remplissent pas ses missions les animaux
n'ont pas les conditions de confort donc
chez nous ne l'aurait pas donc en fait
c'est la contrepartie des missions qui
ont remplissons et je dois dire que nous
avons une très bonne écoute nous avons
été soutenu par les députés mais ce
n'est pas passé le gouvernement on a
passé des à la chambre
mais des avions des amendements de tous
les parties et nous allons espérer au
Sénat nous espérons aussi nous voyons
aussi à l'archer dans quelques jours et
nous espérons au Sénat que nous savons
déjà que les parties de la majorité
comme de l'opposition vont de nouveau
présenter un amendement dans ce sens
alors
dossier nous vous donnerons les les
dernières avancées merci à vous deux je
rappelle donc le cabinet ABC fort-value
a donc planté ses 164 arbres du côté de
Thoiry cette année on termine ce journal
par du sport et ce week-end se déroulait
le premier trophée West Yvelines de
cyclo-cross cette course à étape
permettait aux 180 participants
spécialistes de route VTT et
cyclotourisme de s'affronter sur tous
les terrains Anthony hache et le dimoine
après la première étape contre la montre
les spécialistes de la route s'aventurer
dans le bassin de la Boissière sur un
circuit de 3 km très glissant il fallait
donc limiter la casse pour ne pas
dégringoler au classement c'est vraiment
technique surtout être prudent de
manière
dans le bois et ça c'est vraiment c'est
vraiment piège quoi si on arrive un peu
trop vite à tout de suite on tombe pour
ce premier trophée ouest Yvelines ils
étaient 180 par temps issus de toutes
les fédérations de vélo cyclotourisme
VTT ou root et au milieu du peloton le 5
antinois de 16 ans quand un Fabre a
remporté la première étape de
Bois-d'Arcy dans sa catégorie dans la
Boissière il arrive sur son terrain de
prédilection une stratégie particulière
je sais pas mais peut-être dans les
parties techniques savoir bien relancer
avec mettre de la force certaines
parties après dans le dans les parties
sous bois savoir gérer son effort pour
mettre tout ce qu'on a pour la fin après
le dernier contre la montre de dimanche
après-midi quand un Fabre devra
finalement laisser son maillot de leader
aller son Ia David France qui remporte
ce premier trophée West Yvelines
c'est la fin donc de ce journal je vous
retrouve mercredi 18h pour un nouveau
point complet sur l'actualité locale ce
soir sur TV film n'oubliez pas le 7 8
sociétés avec Catherine zolato et ses
invités qui reviendront sur la polémique
autour de l'écotax excellente soirée sur
notre antenne